on était à Rambervillers c'est un petite
ville dans les Vosges je crois qu'il y a
5000 habitants et c'est pas Paris c'est
pas Bobigny donc il y a une espèce de
tranquillité d'esprit
qui fait que cette petite fille se
retrouver toute seule et ça allait à
proximité de chez elle alors c'était
hier elle est partie au square vers 13h
pour retrouver les copains d'accord
quand elle est arrivée au square elle a
pas retrouvé les copains elle est partie
toute seule elle est partie toute seule
et c'est parce que c'est parce que c'est
dans cette ville là si vous voulez c'est
ça ce serait pas on le ferait pas à
Paris
et donc elle arrive dans le square
les copains qu'elle pensait retrouver ne
sont pas là elle fait demi-tour rentre
chez elle
récupère un jouet une balle très
exactement pour pour s'amuser elle joue
dehors elle voit sa mère sa mère est
partie changer la couche de sa petite
sœur et pendant 10 minutes un quart
d'heure rose s'est retrouvé toute seule
dans la rue à un moment donné assise sur
les escaliers de la maison et un autre
moment à jouer à la balle en plus elle
était visible et des tout de rose vêtue
et
à un moment donné sa mère s'inquiète ne
la voit pas demande à sa grande sœur de
la chercher et là tout ça se passe très
vite en quelques heures ce drame c'est
Noé on recherche cette enfance cette
gamine on ne la retrouve pas elle a dit
totalement disparue vers la maman va au
commissariat enfin en tout cas la
gendarmerie pour signaler la disparition
de sa fille
et tout de suite la police municipale
les gendarmes se battent patrouille dans
la dans le village et ils arrivent très
rapidement à
soupçonner un individu un jeune un type
de 16 ans qui a un comportement pour le
moins particulier et ils vont le
questionner et il va faire une fausse
déclaration en disant en gros qu'il a vu
cet enfant parce que c'est c'est le but
de l'enquête de la police
ordonnant une direction fantaisiste il
est confus dans ses propos et les
policiers le laissent partir mais en
même temps on sait où le retrouver et à
16h30 très exactement c'est ce même
individu ce gamin de 16 ans qui va
appeler les la police pour dire
il y a un sac en plastique devant chez
moi et il y a le la petite fille que
vous cherchez elle est dans le sac en
plastique devant chez moi
les gendarmes arrivent sur place il y a
rien devant le domicile de ce de ce
jeune homme les gendarmes pénètrent à
l'intérieur de la maison c'est le
logement de la mer de celui qui
s'appelle Grégory mais qui s'appelle
comme ça
et là ils vont découvrir dans la
première pièce dans laquelle il rentre
un sac plastique qui contient le corps
de la malheureuse gamine de 5 ans
alors le suspect donc c'est un jeune
homme de 16 ans
déscolarisé décrit comme instable par
beaucoup de monde à commencer par son
oncle qui le qualifie même de débile et
de pédophiles regardez
parce que moi j'ai mes petits enfants
aussi donc on a reçu des messages toute
la nuit et l'année dernière il a fait
une tentative de viol sur une gamine ils
l'ont mis en Forbach pourquoi il a lâché
c'est ça la loi française c'est un
pédophile reste un pédophile il est
débile un mec qui fait des trucs comme
ça pourquoi alors là
c'est dur ce qu'il dit mais c'est fort
et c'est normal il parlait il est comme
nous choqué son oncle alors il y a un
témoignage qui fait énormément réagir
celui de la maman de rose Bianca qui a
témoigné évidemment son état et celui
d'une maman qui est dévastée regardez
j'arrive pas à poser c'est trop dur je
savais pas qu'il fallait un cadavre
qu'il faut aller des témoins détruits
que moi comme mes enfants comme toute ma
famille pour qu'il puisse voir et qu'il
puisse réagir
je veux juste que la justice soit faite
je veux juste que la personne qui a fait
ça c'est bien responsable de ce qu'il a
fait équipé bien parce que moi je paie
avec toute ma vie mais je suis plus en
confiance ici je suis plus je suis
détruite
c'est très dur donc les images alors
c'est c'est BFM TV qui était là derrière
critiqué pour pour avoir diffusé cette
interview origine je comprends pas
pourquoi honnêtement parce que c'est un
témoignage très fort et puis toute la
famille aussi au-delà de de l'épouvante
parle de la situation de ce jeune homme
donc nous place sur le débat de la
justice donc moi je trouve que c'est un
témoignage très fort que cette mère a eu
le courage de parler dans des
circonstances terribles et je comprends
pas les critiques autour de BFM sur ce
sujet là c'est alors c'est un autre
sujet on en reparlera mais c'est vrai
que donc les gendarmes se rendent donc
sac poubelle dans lequel se trouve le
corps de la jeune fille la petite fille
dénudée pas devant chez le jeune homme
mais dans l'appartement de sa mère si tu
as seulement 300 mètres de la maison de
rose je précise que sa mère était
absente depuis quelques jours d'accord
donc lui il était quoi il était tout
seul il était tout seul à 16 ans alors
que son père habite à 300 mètres de
large mais il avait choisi de rester
seul
au domicile de sa maman alors il y a une
voisine qui affirme que plutôt dans
l'après-midi question qui va nous faire
froid dans le dos il va avoir une
voisine il lui pose une question il
cherchait où se trouvait les containers
à poubelle
donc manifestement le crime avait déjà
été commis et il voulait il cherchait à
se débarrasser du corps
bon vous avez vous avez bien noté que
tout ça est très confus en réalité son
mode opératoire est très confus
il appelle il dit n'importe quoi à la
police il appelle ensuite la police pour
leur dire que le corps se trouve devant
son domicile alors qu'on lui demande
rien et
il va demander à la voisine
où se trouve les containers à poubelles
alors qu'il habite quand même dans ces
dans il est originaire de ce village
mais bon
du côté des voisins c'est la sidération
et un témoignage est assez choquant
c'est celui de Nourdine dont la fille de
10 ans a été approché lundi par ce même
jeune homme regardez
en train de course de Épinal puis sur la
route ma fille elle me dit il y a un
jeune homme qui m'a proposé si je
voulais un chaton puis ma fille elle
aime bien les chats donc ah oui tu l'as
tu l'as là puis elle lui dit non il est
chez moi mais viens avec moi si tu veux
alors elle a eu peur elle a pris peur
elle a pas voulu y aller avec
alors et notre voisine qui le croisait
souvent décrit une personne très bizarre
avec des comportements inapproprié
mais même même dehors il parlait tout
seul même quand il y avait pas le vélo
il parlait tout seul il avait fait des
trucs sexuels en fait des des
attouchements il a posté des enfants et
là ça fait deux trois jours qui tournait
enfin je comprends pas franchement ça
m'inquiète quand même parce qu'il y a
des enfants dans le bâtiment il avait
accosté une de mes nièces une de mes
cousines vous voulez lui donner un chat
qui il avait plein de chats chez lui
puis bah les petites filles elles savent
pas forcément et puis elles l'ont suivi
quoi
non non elle a eu de la chance alors
TPMP il y a un autre voisin qui
connaissait bien le suspect qui a pris
la parole contrairement aux autres
témoignages lui décrit une personne et
donc et sans problème écoutez
[Musique]
donc c'est vrai que les voilà c'est très
intéressant ce témoignage parce que ça
montre en quelque sorte le double visage
on retrouve ça dans les témoignages et
on retrouve ça vous allez pouvoir en
parler monsieur dans les expertises
psychiatriques c'est-à-dire une
expertise a dit aucun problème et
l'autre a dit immaturité déficience
mentales légères autocentré etc donc on
a quelqu'un à double visage le petit
jeune exemplaire mais d'un autre côté le
type qui est le jeûne qui revient dans
son village et qui agresse sexuellement
ça passe à l'autre alors ça pose
plusieurs questions la première c'est la
dangerosité d'un tel individu qui n'a
pas été repéré
mais sauf que il y a quand même des
dossiers très lourds le concernant même
si il a été placé mais sauf que la loi
précise bien que il ne peut être placé
que six mois renouvelable une seule fois
donc c'est pour ça que on était obligé
de le faire sortir au bout d'un an c'est
là où il faudrait peut-être et peut-être
et on n'arrête pas de dire ça et je sais
mais moi je sais de plaider pour qu'il y
ait une réforme de la justice à ce sujet
et qu'il y ait des gens qui soient
formés pour repérer ce genre d'individus
de la justice va dire qu'on au delà de
ça ce serait plus de pardon
je disais au-delà de ça il suffit de
modifier la loi pas très compliqué on
laisse ressortir des gens qui ne sont
pas guéris mais on les laisse ressortir
parce que ils ont épuisé le délai de de
la pas de la détention ce qui va se
passer c'est que tout le monde va dire
c'est inadmissible on espère que ça se
reproduira pas c'est qu'on a eu on a eu
des trucs tous les trois mois ici on le
sait et puis dans trois mois il va avoir
une autre affaire ils vont dire et puis
il y aura rien de fait comme d'habitude
donc je vais vous dire ça c'est voilà et
elle a et je veux dire des des voilà et
c'est on on disait la même chose la
dernière fois voilà et on le redit la
même chose maintenant et quand on dit ça
on va nous dire oui mais vous avez vu
Hanouna il surgit non mais il est
dangereux pour lui il est dangereux
voilà elle a la justice il faudrait que
les lois soient revues le ministre dit
qu'il faut pas réagir à chaud qu'on
instrumentalise et après
tout la passion maintenant mais
attention à la passion j'entendais dans
un commissariat cet après-midi ou je me
trouvais que quelqu'un voulait réclamer
le retour de la peine de mort etc c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué et beaucoup plus
complexe et c'est on est dans le
registre vraiment de la psychiatrie pour
l'histoire de Lola on sait même pas où
ça on est d'ailleurs l'histoire
c'est en cours tout est en cours bien
sûr mais alors il faut se servir des des
drames comme ça les parents ils veulent
une chose les parents qui vivent des
drames comme ça ils veulent que ça se
reproduise plus pour les autres enfants
donc la maman de Lola soit au ciel doit
voir qui c'est passé même la famille du
présumé suspect qui disait on comprend
pas pourquoi il est sorti il était super
dangereux bien sûr
ici ici on est c'est bon ici on marche
sur la tête on va écouter le maire de
rambervilliers Jean-Pierre Michel qui a
indiqué que le suspect à orienté les
policiers sur une fausse piste comme
vous l'avez dit regardez
d'après les informations qui m'ont été
transmises le suspect dans un premier
temps avait donné des informations qui
ont dirigé le groupement de gendarmerie
dans une fausse piste puisque il
indiquait que la fillette il avait perçu
dans une direction tout à fait l'opposé
d'où elle était retrouvée et encore plus
foule selon le maire de rambervilliers
l'adolescent cherchait à se rapprocher
de jeunes enfants et avaient des gestes
déplacés à caractère sexuel regardez
un jeune homme qui a déjà fait parler de
lui il y a quelques temps pour défaire
un petit peu apparentés à ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui où il y avait tendance
à
s'approcher et à se faire approcher de
jeunes enfants et pour avoir des des
gestes apparemment des gestes déplacés à
caractère sexuel tiens maintenant on
sait toujours tout après en fait donc
après voilà là il y a eu un drame on
sait tout après ça va avance pourquoi
après c'est les services municipaux ont
eu peur quand ils l'ont vu réapparaître
dans ce village comme c'est un tout
petit village donc on le savait quoi
c'est oui Jean-Michel on le fait pas en
France mais comme d'habitude en France
on protège toujours les agresseurs et
pas les victimes alors que dans d'autres
pays quand il y a un agresseur sexuel
qui est dans un quartier les autres
habitants sont prévenus qui habitent à
certains adresses quelqu'un qui a déjà
un passé de criminel sexuel et du coup
on prévient les enfants ne t'approche
pas si il parle refuse tout ce qui te
propose pour minima
forcer enfin faire une bulle autour de
lui pour que personne n'approche alors
qu'en France il y a affiché les
agresseurs sexuels mais bien sûr
personne ne communique et on prévient
pas les habitants qui a quelqu'un qui
est dangereux dans l'ordre dans leur
quartier c'est incroyable mais c'est
incroyable je vous dis c'est c'est ici
on marche sur la tête de la jeune Rose
qui a témoigné également et réclame
justice ça ne veut pas écarter le terme
d'irresponsabilité et explique pourquoi
regardez je veux parler aux gens qu'ils
ont des enfants malades et des gens
psychiatres
si les laissent pas dans les maisons de
psychiatrie qui les gardent enfermé pour
qu'il prenne plus la vie des autres
innocents peut-être celui qui a fait ça
il savait pas ce qu'il faisait mais si
les parents qu'ils ont tout leur tête
ils avaient su garder leur enfant à la
maison il aurait pas fait ça mais si on
s'est manipulé à un enfant de 5 ans ça
veut dire qu'il avait tout sa tête et on
demande à la justice qui fait justice
comme il le faut
non mais c'est oui c'est
incompréhensible très franchement
février 2022 il est mis en examen pour
séquestration viol agression sexuelle
sur mineur de 15 ans il fait un an il
ressort il doit être suivi par la
Protection judiciaire de la 6 mois
de prison
et il ressort et là il y a un absence de
suivi total c'est incompréhensible
exactement
la seule solution enfin il y a deux
solutions soit on ne laisse plus les
enfants dans la rue comme ça ils seront
plus enlevés mais c'est hallucinant soit
on prévoit quand on a des profils aussi
dangereux que celui-ci de les garder
au-delà d'un an c'est cette règle des 1
an qui ridicule mais sinon les
surveilles Michel on peut pas entendre
ce que vous voulez moi je suis légalisme
et là on peut pas entendre Michel c'est
pas possible justement
il a raison il a arrêté
il y en a trop vous le savez très bien
et même s'il y avait une obligation de
suivi et de soins ils viennent en
consultation pour avoir une attestation
on va remettre et qui ne servira
strictement rien vous nous dites que le
système c'est complètement
pas du tout on est totalement révoltés
on arrête pas de vivre des drames toutes
les tous les mois
donc il faut des gens qui autant vous
dire le ministre de l'autisme veut dire
non il réagissent à chaud voilà donc il
faut des gens qui soient forts
[Musique]
de ce qu'on va lui reprocher pour
l'instant il est en garde à vue la garde
à vue se termine ce soir ou demain on
est plutôt demain
ce qui est certain c'est enlèvement
séquestration ce qui est certain aussi
c'est le meurtre
est-ce qu'il l'avait prémédité ou pas ça
peut modifier un peu le il y aura le
tour des choses et en fonction
d'autopsie si elle a été ou non agressé
sexuellement apparemment il a moins de
16 ans quelques mois ou quelques
semaines de mois ça va couper la peine
en deux de toute façon c'est à dire s'il
a 20 ans c'est automatique il n'a que la
moitié de la peine c'est pas automatique
il peut y avoir des dérogations après 16
ans mais pas avant 16 ans ce matin bien
entendu un avocat pénaliste qui disait
quelques semaines
que les jeunes de maintenant les 15 mecs
de 15 ans c'est pas des mecs de 19 ans
la deuxième guerre mondiale
on marche sur la tête dans ce pays
surtout ça nous rend fou ici et après
c'est nous qui sommes les fous pour les
autres pour les pour les bien-pensantes
et nous les fous ici pour moi les fous
c'est vous voilà je vous le dis les fous
c'est vous et vous continuez à être des
des je vous dis c'est continuer à dire
qu'on est fou ça nous va parce que ce
qui se passe actuellement et je vois que
personne ne réagit et on voit que des
drames se succèdent et il y a jamais
rien fait comme avec moi dernière fois
les mecs arrivent ah bah oui on espère
que ça va bien se passer on est on est
vraiment pense aux familles et puis on
espère que ça va pas se reproduire on va
tout faire pour et tu fais rien pour on
réagit pas là en l'occurrence ça serait
pas compliqué qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
faire ben ce que je disais tout à
l'heure c'est prolonger le la fameuse
durée d'un médecin euh tant que on ne
sort les gens que quand ils sont soignés
si tentait qui qu'on peut les soigner
qui puisse
guérisons tout de même mais il faut la
loi j'espère mais on ne peut pas
remettre des gens qui ne sont pas guéris
on liberté ça fait ce que ça fait on a
un autre problème également c'est que la
psychiatrie et le part en pauvre de la
médecine actuellement et on n'a pas de
moyens et on a plein de pardon pour le
terme je vais me faire assassiner par
tous mes confrères on a plein de fous en
liberté dans les rues il peut être
considéré comme fou lui-même
quand il posait son vélo il lui disait
tu bouges pas je reviens tout à l'heure
on rigole mais moi vous me faites mais
c'est parce que moi parce que on va
observer ça va être considéré ça dans la
faire évidemment voilà évidemment donc
moins de 16 ans considéré comme
irresponsable donc oui on espère que
c'est pas parfait
[Musique]
donc oui
et ses parents ils sont alors son père
est là dans le dans le village ça marche
le père oui je crois qu'il a
il prend pas du tout les patins de son
fils c'est normal non mais il essaye
même pas qu'elle des fois ils essayent
un peu de défendre entre la justice et
ma mère je disais Camus je choisis ma
mère
là non il pense que c'est des gens qui
sont totalement dépassés par les
événements et la soeur se défend en
disant c'est pas parce que c'est mon
frère on n'est pas tous coupables quoi
donc c'est terrifiant dans une ville de
5000 habitants avoir son frère un membre
de sa famille qui a commis ce type de la
justice pas pour le moment par ma
connaissance non il va laisser l'enquête
se poursuivre je voulais juste revenir
sur ce qu'a dit Monsieur et qui est très
vrai il me fait froid dans le dos c'est
que vous avez dit et vous avez tout à
fait raison en France on est incapable
d'assurer le suivi par faute de moyens
donc nous avons Cyril des dizaines des
centaines peut-être des de meurtriers de
violents puissances qui se promènent
dans nos rues parce qu'on peut pas les
suivre et ça vous l'avez dit c'est très
vrai c'est très simple c'est un traçable
c'est incroyable ça on ne peut pas
tolérer
ça là il faut faire quelque chose suivi
bah oui mais c'est pas possible on peut
pas laisser des affaires chimiques
en hospitalisation non mais ce qui est
ce qu'il dit et ceux qui nous écoutent
ce soir à 21h13 on en direct doivent se
dire on vit dans un pays
on est fou c'est-à-dire tout marche à
l'envers il y a pas un truc qui marche
droit je suis désolé les mecs
excusez-moi de vous dire ça tout marche
à l'envers
dans nos rues c'est ça et là c'est
incroyable il faut que ça change là
Michel vous êtes d'accord aussi là on
peut tout réussir impossible ce type de
drame qui se répète à un moment c'est
impossible la France ne peut pas tolérer
ça moi encore une fois je suis souvent
légaliste mais là c'est on ne peut pas
supporter ça c'est insupportable ce qui
s'est passé donc faut que ça changeable
exactement tous ceux qui nous regardent
et tous ceux qui ont voilà qui ont des
enfants qui ont et on se met tous à la
place et pour ne pas d'ailleurs on se
met tous à la place de cette famille et
on se met tous on imagine tout ce qui
est ce qui a dû vivre cette cette petite
fille et on est on joue on a la rage
voilà je vous dirai on a la rage on se
dit parce que rien n'est fait tout est
fait en dépit du bon sens rien n'est
suivi il y a pas de suivi c'est toujours
on s'apitoie on dit que ça se reproduira
plus puis ça se reproduit encore c'est
insupportable il y a rien de fait pour
que ça ne se reproduise plus donc voilà
donc après on va encore me dire oui et
si on a un bah moi je vais pas peur de
le dire ce soir voilà je vous dis il
peut faire des billets sur Radio France
sur France Inter le mini de la justice
peut aller parler sur France 5 et dire
que voilà on
on se réagit et ben nous on réagit comme
la plupart des Français comme vous qui
nous regardez ce soir et qui doivent
être meurtri et très énervés parce qu'il
s'est passé qu'ils disent encore encore
un drame encore un drame et on va encore
recommencer et dans trois mois on va
encore recevoir Michel-Marie et dans les
vitesses on aurait pu l'éviter c'est ça
la population schizophrène on aurait pu
l'éviter c'est vrai il y a des fous
partout un mec qu'on a qu'on contrôle
les parents on sait pas d'où il sort il
vient et tu es une gamine de 5 ans là
c'est un enfant c'est un un gamin qui
tue une enfant c'est un truc de
fouiller il a déjà un café il a déjà été
survé c'est pas un actisonné mais
celui-là il fallait le canaliser
celui-là il était dangereux il fallait
canaliser c'est pas un fou qui est sorti
de nulle part c'est un fou qui sort de
nulle part on dit ok ça c'est terrible
mais là on le savait donc qu'est-ce
qu'on fait c'est comme il disait pour
Lola Lola c'est pareil en même temps le
jugement les parents attendent mais vous
avez de quoi vous avez pas d'éléments on
les a on a tous les éléments ce que tout
ça on a repris notre vie
là mais les paroles
leur vie elle a été brisée et je peux
vous dire qu'aujourd'hui
elle a été brisée c'est tout voilà
aujourd'hui leur vie elle est brisée
voilà c'est tout